something's been on my mind lately and i
have to get it off
my chest this book right here because i
have been reading
oathbringer i keep thinking back to
words of radiance you know i enjoyed it
the first time i read it but
the more i think about it the more i
reminisce the more
it becomes such a memorable experience i
mean just the amount of memorable scenes
in this book is just incredible first
off this is
going to be a spoiler discussion of a
particular scene in
words of radiance so if you don't want
to hear spoilers about words of radiance
and
the way of kings then don't watch this
go watch some other videos that i made
uh i'll pop them up just wherever just
go watch them let's get to the scene
obviously we know what the scene is it
involves
a lot of stormlight it involves caledon
adeline and kaladin
fighting together in the arena that's
not the scene i'm talking about you were
wrong i misled you
no no no we're talking about a scene
that comes a few chapters before
if that duel didn't occur i think this
scene would be the standout scene in the
book besides well
the other one with caledon getting its
powers back and then the other one and
that other one
and that other one point is there are so
many amazing scenes in this book that
you could pick out as
your favorite but the scene and
basically the whole chapter i want to
talk about is chapter 52
titled into the sky people might
remember this as the scene where kaladin
finally learns to fly interestingly
this is not just a caledon chapter see
up until this point
almost every chapter in the stormlight
archive
was sectioned off between characters but
it was in this chapter he is going
very rapidly between a scene with
shillon
and a scene with kaladin i would be
interested interested
to know if they were written as separate
chapters and then combined
it just worked so damn effectively i
honestly wish that more chapters were
written
with that interchange for those of who
you who don't remember starts off with
caledon strolling along the shattered
plains
not very happy about bright lord amaram
is sort of responsible for tien dying
and
is directly responsible for kaladin
being branded the slave and losing his
shard blade
kaladin is stewing on this and he wants
to fly like the assassin and why he
wants to be prepared and it's a very
exciting scene because you're following
the logic am i going to make this work
he checked over his shoulder
he passed the guard post and now nobody
was close enough to see him so
belt laden with bags of spheres kaladin
stepped off into the chasm
and then were in a challan scene within
the same chapter shalon did not care for
sadius's war camp so what is shalon
doing well she's
working-ish for the ghost bloods as vale
her persona that she's crafted she's
trying to get information from bright
lord amaram who is one of sadia's
generals
in this process she is learning how to
master her
light weaving skills just as kaladin is
trying to master his own skills
we jump back and forth rapidly like
sometimes not even a page passes before
we're back this whole chapter is like
very complex and involves jumping
between caledon
and shalon doing very technical skill
related things shalon is sneaking into
this
home and trying to impersonate other
people and get information for the ghost
bloods which she kind of works for but
doesn't and then
the real blow hits when she sees
amram is wielding the shardblade of her
brother helleran he is wielding the
blade meaning that he must have killed
helleran
however she doesn't know that we know
that kaladin
was the one who got the blade first
before amaram killed his friends and
whatnot
we know in this revelation much more
than shalon shalon just thinks that
amaram is a murderer which we already
knew but now we know on top of that
kaladin killed shalon's brother that's a
big deal
that blow of information is accompanied
with
this soaring kaladin is soaring and
feeling
light in life at the same time that
shalon gets this terrible information
about amaram
we are grounded with kaladin and cell
and at the end of the chapter
kaladin is still thinking about how he
could kill amaram he could still
sneak in there like the assassin in
white and get away with it he could
frame the assassin and wife for amram's
murder this tension between him and cell
between him and his duty and
him and honor and this promise that he's
made this tension is getting worse and
worse
shalon and kaladin's character arcs are
merged within this chapter in this kind
of perfect
synchronicity where they're both
leveling up skill-wise together
and they're both getting massive blows
to their
own self-confidence so their
self-confidence builds up and then
is struck down i know adeline and
kaladin you know fighting back to back
that's that's a great scene and
caledon finally getting sill to come
back fighting off moash and
there's just so many wonderful scenes in
the book but when i look back on the
book and i think about
perfectly constructed moments and i
think this one's a bit underrated
you know khalid and learning to fly
that's a huge deal and it's a magical
moment and i think that's what i love
about it
sanderson is so focused on the technical
aspects of his magic on this hard magic
system that sometimes the wonder
gets missed that's fine you know it's
like a scientific approach to the magic
systems there are certain wonder aspects
you know the fun
the thrill of using this magic and i
think in that scene he
perfectly have this well the logical
figuring out
figuring out how to use the lashings in
the right way but also
just the wonder of the act and the magic
itself
combine that with jalon's sleuthing and
getting important information that we've
been craving to get as readers we want
more info
so much is packed into that one chapter
because of this cross-cutting if it had
been two separate scenes would not have
been nearly as memorable
i will wrap this up i really just wanted
to talk about this
one chapter which for whatever reason
just sticks in my mind you know the more
i think about
and reflect upon words of radiance the
more it grows in my memory
what does everyone else think uh what is
your favorite scene from
stormlight archive i hope that this was
this was
mildly interesting thanks for watching
like and subscribe if you have not
already
and